ce n'est pas parce qu'il est très
critique envers le sport de haut niveau
qu'il ne le regarde pas même si certains
comportements lagaf' le côté je conteste
toujours l'arbitraire
ça ça me tue commentateurs fait toujours
qui la ramène pour dire ah ouais et
finalement y avoir un glissement
il n'y a pas que ça commentateurs qui
finalement l'est arbitres en tulle
ancien journaliste et ancien professeur
de droit mais chez le kenya se bat
contre les idées reçues
pour lui le sport c'est synonyme d'
imposture
je pense effectivement que le sport
dissimulent des dessins muraux sous en
se rendant en arguant de valeurs morales
et c'est qu'il ne près qu'il prêche mais
qu'il ne porte jamais tous les discours
au cours du siècle donc toujours
effectivement dit le sport il est bon
pur loyal et c'est fraternelle mais il a
des déviations et moins ma thèse c'est
que le sport il est un segment pervers
c'est à dire il ne peut pas être
autrement qu'il est pervers pourquoi
parce que effectivement les perverse
sais que c'est pas des perversions du
sport c'est qu'à partir du moment où
vous mettez des gens en opposition vous
avez nécessairement l'esprit de
compétition la gagne le rendement le
record bien vous avez le dopage avait
lancé et toute l'histoire des 1900 peu
près de l'origine du sport
voilà le prouve
une imposture doublée d'une absence de
débat michel caillard regrette qu'on ne
puisse pas débattre d'un sujet aussi
sociétales ça mobilise des foules
énormes et finalement au bout du compte
il ya aucune réflexion par exemple sur
ce phénomène de foule
pourquoi des gens s'identifient à des
personnes qui gagnent en deux ou trois
mois ce que immobilier pendant toute
leur vie
on peut roi poser la question pourquoi
votre avis parce que c'est la vie par
procuration on s'identifie à des
gagnants nous crie après des hommes
politiques d'épidémie drôme est quelqu
un qu à 1100 milles dans l'impression
que c'est normal transport rennes chose
même la photo de couverture qu'il avait
choisi il n'a pas pu l'imposer à son
éditeur sûrement parce que pas assez
politiquement correct je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus fort et ça montre
effectivement qu'on pouvait être
manipulé très jeune c'est à dire
effectivement moi ça m'inquiète toujours
du monde de voir des tout-petits comme
ça faire des gestes un peu obscène
avec quelqu'un qui est à turlure et
qu'on à peinturlurer c'est à dire que
lui n'a rien demandé
le titre le score comme imposture comme
servitude absolue michel caillat et ce
n'est pas une surprise ne soutiendra pas
la candidature de paris pour les jeux
olympiques de 2024